I'm pretty sure I gotta go up the stairs  but I  it's gonna be rural because I don't play  scary games very off don't you hate  playing these games like alone with no  light oh I don't think I can get through  here oh my god sure like each door  something's gonna pop out Oh  [Music]  Biggie's has got his like guts taken out  it's definitely a lot better than it  used to be especially with the graphics  how really looks  [Music]  I'm pretty sure I got to go up the  stairs but I by opening doors look I  cannot believe that they just scare me  like that I thought I was coming here  just to play game but I gotta get her  this  [Music]  I'm glad they brought it back I mean I  think resident evil is a classic and  just about everyone slayed this game  look gosh so graphic  you